Centroamérica latina es la región peor
parada como avanzábamos en este ranking
A qué se debe principalmente Y qué
conclusión se saca de ello
Hola buenas noches Rodrigo Sí la verdad
es que las noticias no son alentadoras
para nuestra región por cuarto año
consecutivo sacamos cuarenta y tres
puntos de cien en promedio donde cero es
más corrupto y donde cien es menos
corrupto Y la verdad es que vemos pocos
avances y países al fondo de la tabla e
incluso en países que tienen buen nivel
o buen desempeño como chile un
estancamiento En los niveles en la lucha
contra la corrupción y vemos en este
informe que Venezuela Haití Nicaragua
ocupan los tres últimos puestos Qué
similitudes hay entre estos países para
ser los peor calificados de la región
bueno tenemos la verdad estamos con
instituciones muy débiles estados
fallidos dictaduras estados autoritarios
donde efectivamente no hay capacidad
alguna es de luchar contra la corrupción
en el caso de Venezuela podemos hablar
incluso de una cleptocracia pero yo
diría que además lo que nos preocupa es
que estos países que tienen un claro
déficit democrático y de lucha contra la
corrupción eh No son la excepción en la
región y se le están sumando noticias
preocupantes en otros países cercanos
como puede ser Guatemala Honduras El
Salvador y donde También tenemos que
tener la alerta puesta y qué haría falta
para que los índices de corrupción
mejoraran no solo en estos países en
toda la región
bueno claramente necesitamos fortalecer
mucho más las instituciones nosotros
creemos que por ejemplo algo que
preocupa mucho en América Latina es la
debilidad y la falta de independencia de
los sistemas de Justicia esto obviamente
acrecienta la impunidad y también
produce que hay un terreno fértil para
el crecimiento del crimen organizado y
mayor violencia y seguridad eso es algo
que caracteriza a la región eso es algo
que además hemos visto como ha forzado
también el fenómeno de la migración que
también genera un riesgo para mujeres y
para niñas que las hace víctimas
perfectas por ejemplo de la trata de
personas y hemos visto como este crimen
organizado están empezando a ser un
fenómeno transnacional llegando a
distintos países incluso países que
tienen sus aliados fuerte como el propio
chile por lo tanto creemos que hay que
enfrentar este fenómeno no obviamente en
cada país de acuerdo a la
constitucionalidad pero también de una
manera colectiva el tema organizado la
corrupción empieza actuar de manera
colectiva bueno quizás Nosotros también
tenemos que luchar contra la corrupción
de una manera más organizada más
coordinada y colectiva
una de las cosas interesantes también
que menciona el informe es la
colaboración de países con bajo índice
de corrupción con otros altamente
corruptos nos referimos aquí a nivel
mundial Qué papel juegan estas naciones
en la perpetuación de la corrupción y en
muchas ocasiones de los problemas
políticos y sociales que ella implica
exacto de hecho Bueno hay países con
alto nivel de desarrollo y que tienen
mejor desempeño en la lucha contra la
corrupción por ejemplo en Europa
occidental pero también hemos visto
excepto estancamiento incluso es una
caída como en algunos países como el
Reino Unido y el problema es que hemos
visto que si bien estos países tienen
institucionalidad mucho más fuerte
tienen sistemas de prevención de la
corrupción más potente igual han sido
nichos de lavado de activos o donde es
dinero corrupto de otros países como por
ejemplo de los oligarcas rusos se
instala de una manera bastante tranquila
en nuestros países y probablemente no
sabía reaccionado de una manera mucho
más potente hasta la invasión de Rusia a
Ucrania Entonces yo creo que
efectivamente necesitamos que esta
cooperación sea para los dos lados
porque muchas veces puedo tener países
con mejor institucionalidad con mejor
desempeño en la lucha contra la
corrupción pero que igual tiene un
efecto en generar esta desigualdad y
corrupción en países que tienen peor
desempeño y que tienen mayores niveles
de Desi gualdad